hello what can I get for you guys this  evening yeah no I totally hear you on  your mouth my parents are crazy like  like crazy like I cut off connection  with my parents like four or five years  ago you all right there um yeah yeah I'm  fine I'm just up washing my hands  getting clean yeah well he's a  philosopher but she is loving everything  you're saying right now you are killing  it oh you're so charming when you're  drunk do you know I gotta say like I'm  having a really good time  you wanna sex  wait you love labyrinth I love labyrinth  oh my god you kind of look like David  Bowie a little bit what can I get for  you guys this evening oh I think we need  another minute  okay thank you do you just want to go  get a hamburger or something this place  is kind of yeah I was gonna say the same  thing actually this menu is insane  [Music]